as stoves could soon get 86 from
kitchens across the country going
forward the US consumer product safety
commissioner is considering a ban on the
appliances for new builds uh it says
those appliances can be a source of
indoor pollution sometimes linked to
Childhood asthma but also the gas no gas
lines in new construction is that about
fossil fuels or is it about sorry I'm
getting in trouble no well no that's
that's short answer it's about climate
change because methane is 80 times more
power than CO2 when it comes to hitting
up the planet so big time but but in
small spaces it's personal health what
what the fact that CNN is now doing
stories on the problems with gas stoves
they it's funny they weren't doing it
last week but suddenly the Democrats and
the Machine want to go after your gas
stoves so now CNN starts telling you
about all the problems with gas stoves
you know people have been cooking for a
fire for a long time cavemen this was a
long time ago they were cooking with
fire fire good